Why shut down a well-liked series?
Because actors leave, creators finish telling
their stories, or a network is ready to move
on.
Here's a look at all the TV shows that will
have told the stories they needed to tell
by the end of 2019.
But be warned: Spoilers ahead!
Legion simply isn't the kind of show that
can go on and on forever.
For one thing, the possibly real, possibly
not-real adventures of Dan Stevens' character
David Haller are just so wildly out there,
there's no way creator Noah Hawley and his
writing staff could've kept up the pace indefinitely.
After all, the story involves a man who spends
much of his time in a mental institution and
doesn't quite have a firm grip on reality…or
his burgeoning superpowers.
"Who were the people at the hospital that
day?"
"No, no, no, no, you're, you're lying, trying..."
"David…"
It's up to the writers to advance the story
to a certain place, especially since Legion
relates to the world of the X-Men: David is
evidently the mutant son of the famed Professor
X.
FX announced that the twisty, turny, highly-engrossing
sci-fi hit will conclude with its upcoming
third season, which began airing on June 24th.
Fortunately, it sounds like this is all in
accord with Hawley's master plan: He evidently
wanted the series to only run for three seasons.
Speaking at a Television Critics Association
event in February 2019, he said:
There's no denying that Batman has always
been a popular character.
The never-not brooding Bruce Wayne and his
rogue's gallery of colorful villains are bonafide
pop culture fixtures, no matter how you slice
it.
There are decades' worth of comic books.
The Tim Burton films from the '80s and '90s.
A slew of animated shows.
And, of course, Christopher Nolan's truly
iconic Dark Knight trilogy.
And then there's Gotham, a clever reimagining
of the Batman story that chronicled the adventures
of a young Bruce Wayne, and also introduced
us to younger versions of Commissioner Gordon,
the Joker, the Penguin, and the Riddler.
Since the show was always building towards
young Bruce Wayne's ultimate transformation
into Batman, it was a concept that eventually
had to reach its foregone conclusion.
Evidently recognizing that fact, Fox renewed
Gotham for a fifth and decidedly final season
during the presentation of its 2018-2019 programming
slate.
Honestly, Gotham fans should feel lucky the
show got another season at all.
It ranked a not-so great Number 129 in the
2017-2018 TV ratings.
It also managed to survive a cancellation
massacre at Fox that involved execs axing
Brooklyn Nine-Nine, The Mick, Lucifer, and
The Exorcist, all in one fell swoop.
Fortunately, Brooklyn Nine-Nine and Lucifer
were ultimately rescued by NBC and Netflix,
respectively…and Gotham got a chance to
wrap up its story on Fox.
On the surface, Broad City was a wild and
wacky comedy about two young women dealing
with nutty characters and situations in New
York City, but underneath all the zaniness,
its five-season run was low-key groundbreaking.
It's arguably the first New York-based comedy
that ultimately didn't glamorize New York.
In every episode, co-creators Abbi Jacobson
and Ilana Glazer portrayed two kooky young
women battling a grimy, confusing, apathetic,
and ludicrously expensive Big Apple.
But it's funny!
"Hello sir, we'd like to report that the sound
was really subpar."
"Woof!"
"The Dolby was nowhere near 5.1…Great, okay."
An endlessly entertaining and eccentric comedy
series, Broad City was, at its core, all about
the deep unconditional love shared between
these two best friends.
Broad City perfectly encapsulated how friendship
often propels you through your twenties…particularly
when you're flailing in the big city, and
on your own for the very first time.
Ultimately, the co-stars and co-creators aged
out of that period in their lives, and so
did their characters.
That's why the show had to come to an end.
As Jacobson told TV Line:
The Big Bang Theory's gang of socially awkward
California scientists always managed to bring
in huge numbers, even at the end of its 11th
season.
In fact, it was the top-rated show on broadcast
TV for the 2017-2018 season.
In advance of the show's 12th season, the
season in which the show surpassed Cheers
and became the longest-running multi-camera
sitcom in history, TV execs began negotiating
seasons 13 and 14.
And that's when actor Jim Parsons balked,
despite the fact that he was being paid roughly
$1 million per episode to portray quirky genius
Sheldon Cooper.
A well-deserved salary, to be sure.
According to Entertainment Weekly, the four-time
Emmy winner effectively said no to $50 million
dollars when he turned down two more seasons.
According to Deadline, Big Bang co-creator
and executive producer Chuck Lorre gathered
the cast in his office after a table read
in August 2018.
That's when a tearful Parsons told his castmates
that he intended to leave the show at the
end of the season.
And then Lorre announced that the 12th season
would, in fact, be the last one for everybody.
He preferred ending The Big Bang Theory altogether
rather than continue on without Jim Parsons.
Or Sheldon Cooper, for that matter.
HBO's monster hit Game of Thrones was quite
possibly the last true "appointment viewing"
to ever air on television.
In the age of Netflix binge-watching and DVRs,
millions gathered to watch the show when it
first aired on HBO Go on Sunday nights...both
to avoid online spoilers, and to immediately
find out what was happening with Jon Snow,
the Lannisters, and Daenerys Targaryen, the
Mother of Dragons.
Based on the series of bestselling fantasy
novels by George R.R. Martin, the Westeros
saga reeled viewers in from its very first
episode in 2011.
But the eighth season, which consisted of
six oversized episodes, was definitely the
show's last.
At least audiences finally know who was destined
to sit on the Iron Throne: No one!
But why would HBO force millions of people
to live in a cold, empty world without the
promise of a new Game of Thrones episode?
Well, the show reportedly concluded because
season eight was the end of the calculated
storytelling plan concocted by show creators
David Benioff and D.B. Weiss.
In 2016, Benioff told Deadline:
To that end, Game of Thrones certainly wasn't
like other TV shows, which often consist of
self-contained episodes or season-long plot
arcs.
As Benioff explained:
Whether or not they succeeded is something
you'll ultimately have to decide for yourself.
At some point, History Channel realized that
historically-based TV programming could include
more than just World War II documentaries.
In 2013, the channel delved into scripted
shows for the first time with Vikings.
Possibly the most violent TV series that's
also ostensibly educational, the drama explored
the lives, families, and seafaring fights
of eighth-century Norse warrior Ragnar Lothbrok
and his kin.
It's just like Game of Thrones…except possibly
sort of real!
Creator and writer Michael Hirst based the
show on the written sagas of Lothbrok, so
Vikings is sorta-kinda based on a true story…and
a true story that ends.
All Hirst set out to do was tell the complete
tale.
And over the course of six well-regarded seasons,
he did just that.
The decision to end Vikings was ultimately
his own.
In January 2019, he told Variety:
Over the last decade, USA has established
itself as a major player in quality cable
television, offering viewers plenty of breezy,
almost airless dramas that usually involve
some element of the law, and lots of extremely
attractive people.
The network's slate of hits includes Psych,
White Collar, Royal Pains, and Suits…the
last of which centers around Mike Ross, portrayed
by Patrick J. Adams.
He's a fiercely intelligent man and quite
the brilliant attorney…despite the fact
that he doesn't even have a law degree to
his name.
Winning case after case while maintaining
his secret, Mike soon meets his match in paralegal
Rachel Zane, portrayed by Meghan Markle.
The show's juicy legal and romantic storylines
brought in millions of fans…and according
to The Sun, a certain Prince Harry was among
them.
When Markle began dating Prince Harry in 2016,
it spelled the eventual end of the show.
As you probably know, the couple fell in love
and got married in a royal wedding for the
ages in 2018.
"All that I am I give to you."
Presumably because she'd be living in England
and devoting her life to charity work and
public appearances, Markle left Suits at the
end of the show's seventh season.
Adams evidently figured that was a good time
to leave too, and Suits' writers crafted a
sweet exit for the couple: They got married
and moved to Seattle to run a law firm.
"You're the husband I've always wanted.
And I can't wait to begin our adventure together."
Suits returned for Season 8 in 2018, without
two of its main characters…and the departure
of Markle and Ross proved too much of a loss
to weather.
Producers called it a day, choosing to end
the show in 2019 after the ninth and final
season of 10 episodes.
Now, they're reportedly focusing on Pearson,
a Suits spinoff starring Gina Torres's character.
HBO isn't the only place to find quality programming
on a cable network for a few extra bucks a
month.
In recent years, Showtime has also made a
name for itself with critically acclaimed
and award-winning fare like Homeland, Shameless,
Ray Donovan, and The Affair.
In 2017, Showtime debuted SMILF, a dark, gritty
comedy from the mind of actress Frankie Shaw.
The Mr. Robot co-star created, wrote, directed,
and starred as Bridgette, the titular single
South Boston mother with a sex drive and a
social life.
"I am sorry."
"I'm sorry."
"Okay, I'm sorry.
No, I'm sorry."
"I'm sorry."
"No, I'm sorry."
The show attracted a sizable audience and
a second season was quickly ordered, but some
serious controversy eventually reared its
head…and it directly led to SMILF's early
and abrupt demise.
In December 2018, SMILF writers reported to
the Writers Guild of America that Shaw had
allegedly separated staffers by race.
Meanwhile, co-star Samara Weaving claimed
that Shaw forced her to film a nude scene
despite her "no nudity" contract clause.
In March 2019, the network said in a statement
that:
And that, as they say, was that.
Transparent aggressively evolved over the
course of three seasons.
The quiet, ultra-subtle Amazon series took
on a premise that had never been fully explored
on American television.
Jeffrey Tambor starred as Maura Pfefferman,
a college professor who finally starts living
her truth: She identifies as a woman.
In other words, she's a "trans parent."
Over the course of four seasons, Transparent
ambitiously expanded into a show that was
not only about gender identity, but sexual
and cultural identity, too...particularly
in how the Pfefferman family explored their
Jewish faith and background.
But Maura's journey remained the core theme
of the show…that is, until producers and
Amazon fired Tambor.
The company launched an investigation after
cast member Trace Lysette accused Tambor of
multiple acts of sexual harassment, and one
instance of assault.
Tabor's assistant Van Barnes also accused
the actor of inappropriate behavior.
"It ran the gamut of sexual harassment, physical
harrassment, and verbal abuse constantly."
With Tambor gone, the show's writers decided
to wrap up the series with a special two-hour
finale that's set to air on Amazon in September
2019, according to Variety.
The death of Maura will figure prominently
in the storyline... and the episode is actually
going to be a musical, if you can believe
it.
"Let's take it from the top."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.